this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform
which allows entrepreneurs to create and
customize their own personal or
professional website more on Squarespace
later in the video so hello and welcome
to yet another episode of biographics
I'm your interim host Carl Smallwood
that's car with a K and then small wood
with a small and then a wood and today
we're talking about Keith Moon the man
who is too wild for rock and roll and as
with all the videos here on biographics
this one is based on original script
submitted To Us by a member of our
writing team that member today being Ru
Alexander who you can follow on the
social media links found below normally
for these videos I'll just wear
something quite conservative simple like
you know just a Blazer and a t-shirt or
like you know jacket and jeans but since
we're talking about you know Moon The
Loon I thought I'd just go dig out my
old denim vest from like my concert days
and put this bad boy on cuz yeah I've
got the old I've got the full got the
Canadian tuxedo look fortunately I can't
do the full huge Atman and go triple
denim which he's like no that's just too
much that's the Canadian 3 piece but
let's get to
it so Alex Cooper a man who isn't
exactly a stranger to rock and roll
extravagance once said this about Keith
Moon nobody could compete with Keith
think about it this way about 40% of
what you've heard about me or Iggy or
Aussie is probably true everything
you've heard about Keith Moon is true
and you've only heard a tenth of it
Moon's bandmates Roger adter once said
Keith lived his entire life as a fantasy
he was the funniest man I've ever known
but he was also the saddest he had an
incredible talent but was so completely
uncontrollable not just a little bit
completely uncontrollable Moon's close
friend and personal assistant dogle
Butler said that Keith was and I quote
one final time was trying to make people
laugh and be Mr funny he wanted people
to love him and enjoy him but he would
just go so far like a train ride that
you couldn't stop and everyone who got
to know Keith had a colorful and
whimiscal way of describing the man
nicknamed Moon The Loon and even though
moon was the drummer for The Who one of
the greatest rock bands that I've ever
lived it was his destructive behavior
and outlandish Antics that for many
ended up defining his legacy and
ultimately cost him his life but before
we get to that we have to start as we
always do at the beginning starting with
early
life Keith John moon was born on August
23rd 1946 in the lon suburb of Wembley
the oldest of three children Alfred and
Kathleen better known as Alf and kitty
Moon once the war was over Al found a
job as a machine operator for a
matologist and little and a year later
baby Keith made it into the world
followed later by Two Sisters even as a
young child moon was obsessed with music
spending countless hours in front of the
family's old gramophone listening to
everything from Nat King Cole records to
traditional Scottish accordion music the
latter of which sucks cuz I listened to
some beforeand I like what does that
sound like Oh I thought bag pites were
bad and I can say that cuz my family
Scottish we don't think it would
surprised anyone to find out that young
Keith or knobby as his father would
calling was a rambunctious and energetic
child who loved getting attention and
wasn't that concerned with getting a
good education a childhood friend
described Noby as always getting into
trouble laughing and joking and farting
he just had that attitude I go to school
and if I don't learn anything who really
gives a toss anyway when he was 12 years
old Moon signed up with a youth charity
called The seadet Core he also joined
their band and picked up a musical
instrument for the first time in his
young life a bugle from the bugle Moon
Advanced to the trumpet but wasn't
particularly good with either one of
them eventually he was allowed to switch
to the instrument that would define his
life from then on the drums Noby didn't
stick around with the cadetes for long
though and when he was 14 he stopped
going to school as well he couldn't
afford his own drum kit so how was he
going to practice well playing the drums
well fate lent a hand in introducing
moon to Jerry Evans an older kid who
shared his fondness for music but also
had his own drum kit at home how
convenient the first time Evans invited
Noby over and allowed him to play on his
set he described Moon as like a madman
set loose on a drum kit with no idea
what he was doing he was just hitting
everything in sight and making a load of
noise he was like the worst drummer
you've ever seen in your life if moon
was going to get better he needed to
practice and to practice he needed his
own drum set and to get his own drum set
he needed money so in 1961 he started
taking evening classes at Harrow
Technical College and showed something
of an aptitude for working with
electronics Moon then found work wiring
transistor radios with a company called
Ultra Electronics which is a great name
for a company stealing it for the next
company that I make it was a menial
9-to-5 job that drove the ungovernable
Moon out of his mind but what he really
wanted was that drum kit so he had to
stick it out fortunately for him his
buddy Jerry had come through Big Time
Evans worked at a music store and he got
a great bargain for his new friend a
premier Pearl blue drum kit good as new
for 75 nicker this was still way out of
Keith's reach but as long as he put in a
15 down payment and his father signed on
as a guarantor the drums were all his to
[Music]
keep although most of Moon's playing
style came naturally to him he did
receive some early guidance from fellow
wemy resident Carlo little who gave you
some lessons at 10 Bob for 30 minutes
and for any like people out there are
familiar with the vernacular of 10 Bob
it's about five British Pence like a
common phrase is if something's quite
cheap it's 10 Bob and a blackb bird's
egg so just you know 50p and stuff you
can find on the ground meanwhile his
friend Jerry became part of the band
called The escorts and knobby would
often attend their rehearsals and gigs
with a giant grin on his face one time
in July 1962 Evans left London on
holiday with his family and the escorts
had a regular run of gigs that they
didn't want to lose they thought why not
give the young kid who's always stood
around looking like an idiot and loves
playing the drums a chance to play the
drums in our band so Keith was if you'll
forgive the pun over the moon this was
his first live gig at the Sacred Heart
Roman Catholic youth club quite
predictably he played the drums like the
true Maniac that he was the audience and
the club manager hated it the escorts
however did not they thought that Moon
style and Stage persona could help them
Stand Out amongst the Sea of cover bands
out there yeah so I was in a cover band
that's why I've got this thing we were
called steel duv because we're a cover
band get it duv covers someone out there
finds that funny show your face this
created an awkward situation they wanted
to keep playing with Keith but what to
do with Jerry their solution was to find
some out of the way gigs and use moon
for those while Evans still played their
regular shows they tried having two
drummers and ultimately they ended up
with none Jerry Evans got promoted his
job decided to focus on that instead of
the intangible dream of becoming a rock
star while Keith Moon being Keith Moon
just sort of drifted away leaving the
escorts without anyone actually saying
it out loud in December 1962 the
16-year-old Keith saw an advertisement
for a drummer from a band called the
beach comers they weren't big but they
were bigger than anything Keith had been
involved in so knobby got his dad's
driving to audition drum kit loaded in
the back only to discover a long line of
other drummers hoping that this would
also be their big break the beach comr
took one look at Keith and immediately
said no he was too young he couldn't
drive he wouldn't even be allowed in
some of the clubs that they played so
they called in another drummer to
audition and he wasn't good enough so as
the first drummer left Keith was
reported saying come on give me a go and
the ban once again said no so a second
drum went to the audition he also wasn't
good enough either and he Z left Keith
again said come on I've come all this
way but the answer was still no the
third drummer auditioned and he wasn't
up to snu so as he left Keith asked
again and then again and then again
fortunately for him none of the other
drummers wild Beach coma so when there
was literally nobody else left and moon
was still standing there eagerly waiting
they finally reled and said okay what
have you got and all the band really
thought they were doing here is humoring
an enthusiastic kid but as soon as Keith
let loose guitarist John Scher described
the moment as like a bomb going off
behind us the beach comers had found
their new Drummer Moon played with the
band for about 18 months sticking mainly
to a regular run of pubs social and
youth clubs with the occasional open act
for a more prestigious ban in a large
event you like a hotel the old field
Hotel was probably their most popular
gig and at the same time he was growing
into the Keith Moon that everyone would
come to know love and be grudgingly
respect with each new show he was
getting louder and cockier he started
using fireworks and smoke bombs on stage
the audience responded quite well to
these Antics and moon relishing in being
the center of attention even started
giving the others pointers something
that was not well received inevitably
the rift between the two sides became
too great to overcome Keith hated
playing ballads like they w the rock and
roll he wanted to play and he want to
try some of that blue stuff maybe some
of that surf rock that just come out of
Sunny Sandy California his personal
Paradise but the main issue was that
Keith was ready to turn this into a
career the beach comr only played
semi-professionally all the members
still had regular jobs but Moon could
not Envision himself doing anything but
play the drums just like with the
escorts there was never really a moment
where Keith said I quit or somebody else
told him that he was fired he just
drifted away and found something else
that he wanted to do there was this band
that had just fired its drum and had an
opening and they used used to go by the
detours but they just changed their name
before meeting Keith Moon to the
who so I'm sure whatever past car was
saying is very interesting but it's time
to take a word from today's sponsor and
when we talk to sponsors I of course
need my comfort
antita and this anti was thrown to me
very haphazardly by my offscreen friends
and guys from behind the scenes Brad and
Nisha so who are we talking about today
so we're going to be talking about
today's sponsor Squarespace hey I know
this one I'm I'm starting to remember
the sponsors and is Squarespace the
service that is basically a website that
makes more websites yeah that's correct
and you can use it to make a website
that does anything hopefully including a
website that makes more websites just
the website Inception keeps going down
is that when you Google recursive on
Google and it just says did you mean
recursive and you keep clicking it it
keeps going in so obviously with
Squarespace you can customize it to your
heart's content basically and I'm a
person who really likes customizing I
say here dressed in a black C and gray
t-shirt shirts believe it or not I'm
very colorful in my day-to-day life I
have dinosaur bedding on underwear
ladies so one of the aspects I think is
great about Squarespace is the fact they
have a fluid engine which is as you
probably know Dragon drop system yeah so
they call it the fluid engine system but
it's Dragon drop and dragon drop it got
it was real bad in the past guys like
you don't know how easy you've gotten it
where you can just go boop boop in
anything you want in out take a template
customize it to your heart's content
like we all like to think we're creative
but we all need that little push like we
need the canvas made always that abbing
paint on it when people tell you oh you
can make anything just create anything I
need some sort of guidelines please just
give me a hint one of the key factors I
think as well is you can check your
analytics so you can see where your
visitors are coming from and what does
it I always say about analytics guys an
analytics are King they are it's a very
underappreciated aspect of making
content online whatever kind of content
it is you're making or share it online
be it photographs recipes appears just
videos of you syncing three pointers in
basketball over and over again you want
to know how many people interacted with
that content and in what Manner they
interacted with it so you can better
tailor your content towards the audience
that you are building or have built as
well as keeping track of the audience
you can also um do email campaigns so
you can send them regular updates and a
mailing list might seem like a thing of
the past but we going full circle guys
cuz this is a video going out on YouTube
and people clicked a button to see this
video and most people don't because
YouTube decides wouldn't you rather it
was you decide who gets to see your
content and what you want to share so
thank you to today's sponsor Squarespace
check out Squarespace at squarespace.com
biographics for 10% off your first
purchase of a website slain using the
code biographics as is tradition for ad
spots guys we do like to end on a bonus
fact not found anywhere else on this
channel y yay so do you know that Elvis
once punched a gun out of Alice Cooper's
hand
no you do because we covered on my it
sounds familiar so like Elvis like the
image of lot people have Elvis in their
head he's probably you know sad fat
Elvis from the end of his life but prior
to becoming sad fat Elvis he was in
remarkable good shape and one of the
things he was obsessed with was karate
so much so that he had a custommade
karate ghee that looked like one of his
trademark jumpsuits and Elvis loved to
show people his karate skills including
other rock stars which culminated in a
moment when Alice Cooper the shock rock
legend was in a hotel room with Elvis
and asked to see some karate moves at
which point Elvis pulled a gun because
another thing Elvis liked to do is just
have guns in and around his person at
all times he pulled a gun out of a
nearby drawer told Alice Cooper it was
loaded turned the safety off put it in
his hand and told Alice Cooper to put
the gun to his head and according to
Alice Cooper at that moment he genuinely
thought about pulling the trigger so
that he would always be the guy who shot
Elvis but before he could finish that
thought Elvis punched the gun out of his
hand tripped him up threw him to the
ground and said that is how you disarm a
guy with a
gun the audition that secured a spot for
Keith Moon on the who is a bit of rock
and roll legend pitch it now it was a
Thursday night in May 1964 and the band
was playing at the old field their
drummer was gone and they were using a
session drum for the show Moon normally
one of the most confident men in the
world was too nervous to just walk up to
the hoop so we had a mutual friend Lou
hunt the manager of the Oldfield do the
introductions for him during a break in
their set the band members cast their
sights on Keith Moon for the first time
and they described him as the
gingerbread man according to according
to basis John an whistle he had a brown
suit a brown shirt brown shoes and he'd
obviously tried to do a Dennis Wilson
and put a blonde streak through his hair
but he must have panicked halfway
through and it had just gone a dark
Ginger color they decided to give Keith
a test and asked him to play Road Runner
by Bo Diddley the track was part of
Moon's usual repertoire so he it
impressed the band told Keith to join
them on stage ining the second half of
that show and play a couple of songs
together he did and surprisingly behave
like his usual Keith Moon self doing a
real number on the drum kit that
belonged to a session musician so much
so that after the show he build a band
an extra5 pounds for damages Moon hadn't
even joined the band and the who were
already paying for the destruction he
left in his wake after the gig lead
singer Rog aduring guitarist Pete
Townsen simply approached Keith and
asked him what you doing Saturday and
the rest as they say is rock and roll
history at least that's the story the
band members reiterated several times in
interviews and later in their own
autobiographies blue hunt reigned on
their parade a little by giving a far
less dramatic and more realistic version
according to him he brought Keith in
during a practice session in an empty
Hall and the whole audition happened
behind closed doors however it happened
though Keith Moon was now part of the
who sort off keeping in line with his
Breezy attitude towards band commitments
Moon later admitted that he'd never ever
been officially asked to join the band
he worked with them on a gig by gig
basis and they just never told him to
stop turning up Moon would later joke
that he'd been just filling in for the
last 15 years and now for a little bit
of off forgotten the who history did you
know that a few weeks after Keith Moon
joined the band they changed their name
again this time they were called high
numbers at the insistance of their new
manager Peter Meen this simply meant a
bunch of cool guys mod lingo if you're
on familiar with the mod subculture you
can watch Quadrophenia to get an idea of
it the point is that the mods were big
with the British youth in the 1960s and
Meen thought they should be the band's
core audience it was under the name High
numbers that the band recorded their
first single called zoot suit with a
bside titled I'm in the face again both
were mod references with the lyrics by
Meen the songs were blatant ripoffs of
two American Blues tracks and really
failed to make the charts fortunately
the band realized this was a failed
experiment to ape somebody else's style
and corrected course soon after they
fired Meen found new managers and
changed their names back to the who then
in January 1965 they released their
first single as the who titled I can't
explain written by Pete townzen and
became popular in the UK this scored a
band a record label deal and its first
television appearance on one of the most
popular music shows in the country BBC's
top of the pops the who will now a
hit Keen to capitalize on their new
found success the who kept recording new
material in December 1965 they were
ready to release their debut album My
Generation promoted using a single of
the same name the sales weren't great
although the critical exception was
hugely POS positive and only improved
over time today it's considered the best
rock and roll albums of all time or at
least one of them Keith Moon got
comfortable in his new role fairly
quickly he's playing style which was all
over the place at times frustrated his
bandmates but then they realized this
energy and Persona gave the who sharper
rock and roll Edge that all the bands
simply did not have it made them more
exciting if not necessarily more
technically proficient and rather oddly
for a drummer especially one of Moon's
enthusiasm disposition and ego Keith
hated playing drum solos and hated
playing them in concerts for example
consider the time that who were playing
a gig at Madison Square Garden which
included a rare live performance of
wasman mainly instrumental track That's
Heavy on the drums and at one point the
other band members paused playing just
to listen to Keith playing the drums but
he wouldn't have any of it after only a
few moments of drumming he shouted drum
solos are boring and stopped in a later
interview Moon clarified his position
stating that he never saw the drums as a
solo instrument rather and to quote him
there to set the beat for the rest of
the music besides playing the drums Moon
also enjoyed singing although his
efforts were not always well received
since even he admitted he was T deaf as
a result Moon would mainly stick to
backing vocals during live shows and
during recording sessions would
frequently annoy the record producers
because he kept making the other band
members Laugh In fact some sound
Engineers simply muted kei's microphone
While others baned him from the studio
during vocal recordings entirely in
typical style Moon never T this
personally but rather saw it as an
opportunity shall we say to create yet
more mischief and he would amuse himself
by finding ways of sneaking back inside
in in fact if you listen to the song
Happy Jack at the very very end you'll
hear a male voice usually said to be
Pete townzen saying I saw you and
reportedly this was director at Moon who
was hiding in a corner like a
goblin in terms of writing the music it
was nearly always town and who carried
the heavy load as a primary songwriter
of The Who however Keith did have a few
composing credits mainly on bides
probably the most interesting one to
mention is the track Dogs Part Two an
instrumental releases a bside to Pinball
Wizard The credited writers are Keith
Moon touser and Jason with the latter
two being the actual
dog the actual dogs of Pete townend and
John en whistle Moon recorded eight
albums with a who between 1964 and 1978
and we're not going to go into each of
them individually because this is a bio
about Keith Moon not the band as a whole
but we will mention their fifth studio
album who's next which became a massive
hit both critically and commercially and
is often regarded as one of the greatest
albums of all time not just within the
rock genre just of all time now Moon had
a few musical projects outside of the
who the most notable being his only solo
album aply titled two sides of the Moon
released in September 1975 which was not
good it was described in reviews as the
perfect expression of drunken
self-indulgence and to quote the most
expensive karaoke album in history and
finally so fascinatingly bad that it is
assumed a certain cult status even
though it featured appearances in the
likes of Joe wall Sherry Nelson and John
Sebastian Moon insisted on singing the
lead vocals on every single track and
only played the drums on three of them
maybe he saw it as an opportunity to
expand his rigns and artist maybe he was
just playing a joke on everybody we
don't know for sure but the end result
was something that was quickly forgotten
and buried in the animals of who history
besides two SIDS of the Moon Keith
occasionally collaborated with other
rockers such as the greatest thief of
American Black Rock Jimmy Page Jeff Beck
and the Beatles he was also featured on
John en whistle own solo album smash
your head against the wall and for the
most part Moon was happy just playing
with the who even though his band mates
knew they always knew there was one
group that could have led him away in a
heartbeat and to quote Roger adultery
the funny thing about Keith though he
was a total Beach Boy not even in the
70s if the Beach Boys had asked Keith to
join them and leave the who he would
left us he was an absolute fanatic that
first night he joined us his hair was
bright Ginger cuz he' gone out and
bought a bottle of peroxide to become a
Californian Beach blonde with his jet
black hair and the peroxide he gone like
a bloody carrot and finally the part we
all want to hear
of course music is only one half of
Keith Moon's Legacy to rock and roll in
fact most people don't remember Keith
Moon for his drumming but for his
Reckless Rock and Roll Lifestyle full of
copious amounts of drugs alcohol and sex
and we're not going to harp on the
subject too much because there's just
too much to cover and it's unclear how
much of it is true but you know being
part of a successful rock band only
allowed moon to indulge in every whim
but actively encouraged him to do so and
we might as well talk about the two
things The Who for destroying their gear
on stage and Wrecking hotel rooms on
tour if we wanted to we could probably
make the entire video just talking about
only Keith pranks but we're going to
stick to the classics and the one that
have got some confirmed like veracity to
them so to start we have when the band
made their American TV debut on
September 17th 1967 on the Smothers
brother Comedy Hour Moon decided to
introduce himself with a bang literally
so by that point he and Townsen had had
their routines worked out and they ended
their set with towns Zen smashing his
guitar and his amps while Keith d smoke
bombs inside of his drums on this
occasion though Moon Theon decided to
use about 10 times the gunpowder than
normal causing injuries to himself when
a piece of flying symbol shrapnel sliced
through his arm and to Town's end he
received the brunt of the explosion and
was visibly dazed afterwards there's
also a rumor that the loud bang caused
fellow guest bet Davis to faint
backstage but the Smothers Brothers
always denied that this was the case no
hotel room was safe from Keith Moon's
anttic smashing the place up and
throwing the Telly out of the window had
become a standard practice for him even
though it added thousands of dollars to
the bill each time he did it Moon never
cared as he was Reckless with his
spending as he was with about everything
else in his life one time though Keith's
quick thinking not only got him out with
paying for the bill but got him an
upgrade to a nicer Suite specifically
when he was staying at a hotel room in
Copenhagen Moon had a water bed in his
room naturally he thought it' be a good
idea to ride it down the lobby
unsurprisingly it burst during the move
causing waves of water to fill the room
and the hallway unperturbed and thinking
quick on his feet Keith called the front
desk to complain the mattress had
exploded while he slept ruining all of
his expens ensive gear and outfits the
manager bought the story of moving to
the presidential suite which moon then
proceeded to trash as well two for the
price of one baby perhaps the most
famous or should I say Infamous tale of
Hotel destruction occurred at the
holiday in in Flint Michigan which
allegedly got the huban fall life from
all holiday in it was when Moon
celebrated his 21st birthday and drove a
Lincoln Continental into the hotel pool
and this is a quintessential legend of
rock and roll law but it appears to be
just that a legend biographers who've
looked into a story have never found any
evidence of it occurring there were no
arrests even though Moon claimed he
spent the night in jail there were no
mentions of it in the local papers and
the who was certainly not banned from
every holiday in hotel John un whistle
himself confirmed it never happened
because Keith Moon couldn't drive this
is a tale that everyone believed because
it involved Keith Moon and that guy was
capable of anything and I think that
more than anything speaks to his legacy
that the story of him driving a car into
the pool of a hotel and getting banned
worldwide from like you know all hotels
in that chain is so believable because
it just sounds like something that's
just that's so Keith eventually though
the predictable happen and Keith Moon
died on September 7th 1978 age 32 in
London apartment that he was renting
from Harry Nelson the same apartment
that Cass Elliot of The Mamas and papers
had died in four years earlier that same
night the cause of death was an overdose
of H Varian a sedative used to combat
alcohol withdrawal however the drug
itself was dangerous addictive and
potentially lethal if mixed with booze
he was not supposed to be taken on
supervis yet Moon persuaded his doctors
to give him a hundreds tablets he should
limit himself to just three pills a day
at maximum but the postmortem found over
30 tablets in his system most of them
still on dissolved Moon died a few weeks
after the release of the who eth album
who are you in a bit of eerie
foreshadowing the album cover shows the
band posing on stage s about giant
speakers cables and other gear front and
center is Keith Moon a director's chair
with the words not to be taken away
stencil upon it and thus ended the
legacy of one of the most famous
drummers in Rock and Roll History so I
hope everybody out there found this
video to be educational entertaining and
informative I certainly found the script
to be all three of those things and if
you are inclined to agree you can follow
today's um author Ru Alexander on the
social media links found below mine are
also down there if you want to follow me
and while you're down there clicking and
pressing things you can like the video
leave a comment with feedback
suggestions other Tales of rock and roll
Deery and uh people you may want us to
cover in future on the channel and
subscribe for more content like this as
I always like to say to everyone out
there go out there and have the day you
deserve and listen to some good music
and crank it up real loud it's what
Keith Moon would have wanted
cheers